thank you very much
so
let me start by talking about the
mentioning two problems that you're all
aware of uh problem one and server
complexity if you want to show explicit
circuit size lower bounds for strong
circuit classes
for the number two improve complexity
you want to show proof size lower bounds
again for strong proof systems
so and perhaps the third hard question
is how are these two questions related
and this is a theme that has been going
on for the last
30 years or so and we've had already
quite some uh
mentioning of this here at our Workshop
so in fact the very first talk lastly
after explaining the true mission of
proof complexity uh started exactly with
this uh this disconnection between uh
started lower bounds and proof size
lower bounds and here's some more
footage I'm not quite sure if you can
see this this was idle yesterday uh
talking again uh that this is really
open in the Boolean world how you can
make such a transfer between circuit
lower bounds and proof size lower bounds
and then explaining how this works in
the algebraic setting
and uh maybe in one line the purpose of
my talk will be to convince you that in
the qbf setting this works in a very
neat and nice way we have a very clean
transfer in both directions in fact
between circuit lower bounds and
proof-sized lower bounds
so what is this actually about so we
have got another quote actually from a
survey by Paul and Tony from about 20
years ago but it's pretty much up to
date and I uh it's again on its
correspondence between I mean at least
this regarding to this point
um between circuit classes and proof
systems and I'll just read the last line
in general the intuition for this
approach is that any tautology that
needs to use and it's proof some concept
that is not representable in complexity
Class C will not be efficiently probable
in C fader
but I mean the important thing is this
is just an intuition and we don't know
how this how to make this work in in the
proposition to me
and maybe the last the last quotation
some of you might know that there's a
proof complexity theme song and actually
this also features here low bounce for
circuits player role where you know this
connection isn't very defined
okay so what's the question exactly let
me just restate it once more
so we have this General belief that
there should be a formal connection
between lower bounds for proof systems
working on sea circuits and lower bounds
for the circuit Class C
as I tried to say before I mean this
isn't made formal yet but just to be a
bit more specific so one example would
be we would we would like to show a
correspondence between lower bounds for
the police or unrestricted circuits and
extended failure because extended
failure can be understood as a proof
system where the lines are just people
and same for other complexity classes
where for instance ac0 mod P circuits
where we do have a circuit lower bound
and ac0 mode and we don't have a circle
where we don't have a proof-sized lower
part
and it was also mentioned before in this
Workshop that I mean we do have
restricted settings various transfer
works one is feasible interpolation but
here we talk about molotron circuits so
it's perhaps not so clear what this how
this relates to resolution perhaps also
for cutting planes uh it will talk a lot
about this in the algebraic setting
foreign
to talk about
uh 25 formulas so maybe just a slide or
two on what we are what what this
actually is so quantify Boolean formulas
qbf we are looking at a complicated
Problems P space complete and just to
mention that in the last 20 years
there's been really extensive work in
qbf solving so it's a really emerging
success story that we see there I mean
paralleling what is done inside but we
are looking at a more complex problem
here
and then also there has been quite some
proof complexity in the last decade or
so
uh so the objects we will look at are
fully Quantified planex formula so that
means we have a we have pre-ex normal
forms you have to quantify a prefix and
then the Matrix will typically be in CNF
and moreover we want that all the
variables appealing in the prefix in the
in the Matrix are Quantified in the
prefix
but it means there aren't any free
variables so such qbfs must be either
true or false there isn't any other
possibility and in accordance with
convention improved complexity we look
at refutation calculator for false qbf
so we will assume that the formulas are
false and we want to refute them
um what is important here is to remember
this game semantics that we know for
qbfs we can interpret it as a two-player
game between existential and Universal
player and what they do is they play
according to the prefix and set the
variables to zero and one
and if the universal wins the universal
wins if a cross gets 45 and otherwise
the existential wins so just let's look
at an example perhaps let's take
something from the last slide
udx extension has to start and maybe he
sets x equal one well then the Matrix
simplifies now U has its turn and I mean
okay if you look at what's left it would
be reasonable for you to also play one
and then no matter what the existential
is doing you falsify a clause to the
universal player has one
I mean this is not a full strategy but
you can make it into a strategy and the
formula is indeed false
okay so the universal player has a
winning strategy on false formulas
and now of course we need some proof
systems
and one of the core proof systems is qbf
and qbf is again resolution it's quite
similar to what we know from the
propositional domain
uh this is actually also one of the
oldest systems in the area goes back to
the 90s
and in a nutshell it's just
propositional resolution plus a new rule
called Universal reduction
so resolution we all know
we have some side condition here that C
or D must not be tautological but I mean
we can we don't need to worry about it
for the moment so this is uh the
classical resolution Rule and we couple
this with a new rule that can eliminate
some Universal variables
so you've got a clause here containing a
universal variable U or literal and you
can drop you and simplify this to c
provided that c does not contain
variables right of U in the quantifier
prefix
so in other words
nothing in this class C depends on you
all the variables in C come left of of U
yeah I mean if you look at the game
semantics you can immediately convince
yourself that this is actually sound
because the universal player once he
reaches his turn to to set you to a
value you I mean he would in this case
obviously set u to zero and that means
stopping the U
it is a simple example suppose this is
your formula and you want to refute it
it's a false formula you want to refute
it in Q U resolution so you do the
resolution step on X here then you've
got a unit class U which by this
Universal reduction you can just talk to
you and get to the end clause
thereby demonstrating there's this
formula as false
okay now it's a it's a nice but not
really difficult observation that this
can be generalized to oil proof systems
that we are almost all approve systems
that we know in the propositional
context
for which I want to define a general
Universal reduction rule
we work again with Phoenix qbfs sp4
and now
that f x u be a propositional line and a
refutation of of Phi so it's any
propositional line if you're uncutting
planes and inequality if you're on
trigger it's a formula whatever your
proof system works with
um and now I'm adding two rules to this
for XM one rule to the system which is
again this Universal reduction rule
uh and the condition is as before that U
is universal with innermost
quantification level in F
so in other words again
nothing in F none of the X variables
will depend on you
and in this case again I'm free at sound
to for the universal player to either
set u equals zero and therefore simplify
the formula or to set u equal one
that's fine
okay you know it's it's really not not
difficult to see that if you start with
any natural line based propositional
proof system like resolution cutting
claims uh polynomial calculus
you can just add this one ruler and get
a sound incomplete qbf system whichever
We Know by by QP for this talk yeah so
QP is sounding complete for pubf
and if you plug in P equal resolution
this is exactly the system to your
solution that I've defined on the
previous slide
okay so what I want to concentrate here
for the remainder of this talk is on
fragrance systems so okay we know
already these I use XM streams and rules
and in fact we've got a hierarchy of
Vegas systems parameterized by the
circuit classes that you use as lines
yeah you can understand all these
fragrance systems as working with
circuits as lines for instance ac0 or
what it is a zero figure is found the
depths fig case zero mod P figure you
use boundary depth failure with mod P
counting gates for times p t c z or flag
you use threshold gates in the circuits
um so here you've got a simulation order
of the systems I mean we've seen that
also before
we've got resolution bound attacks frig
ac0 mod P T C 0
uh nc1 which is then trigger and
extended which is
and the current line of uh where we can
show hard formulas is this red line and
you see ac0 mod P is the strongest
system for which we have lower bounds
and for ac0 more p and above we don't
have anything
okay so now we want to look at these
systems with all these systems you can
transfer into qbf by just adding this
one universal reduction mode as I said
before so we have exactly the same
systems we want to analyze them now in
the qbf context
um so one observation
is that propositional hardness
immediately transfers to this setting uh
if you have a formula five which is hard
for p then if you just existentially
quantify it will be hard for QP for
trivial reasons yeah because uh
there aren't any universal variables
here so you can't use Universal
reduction the only thing you can use is
words from p and then you'd immediately
transfer any of the lower bounds this is
perhaps not really what we are
interested in
um if you want to understand genuine qbf
hardness in the sense that you want to
see where actually they are actually
quantification makes formulas hard that
are not otherwise hard
what you could do is for the systems
that I defined you could just count the
number of for all reduction steps but
you can actually also model this
somewhat more nicely by allowing NPO
records in in the proofs
and let me just show you this
I Define the system QP with an NPO
Oracle and the rules are I mean as
before the rules of the propositional
system P the universal reduction rule
plus I now use these strong entailment
steps yeah the C's are any Clauses for
instance or formulas that you have and
you can derive a new line D whenever the
C is semantically entails this is just
compositional yeah propositionally
entail d
and then for instance impatient work
principle uh you would be able to infer
the empty Clause just in one step yeah
because you can take all the axioms and
get the empty Clause immediately
okay so this isn't formally a cool
geckov post system anymore you need
these NP oracles to verify the
correctness of posts but we are just
interested in showing lower bounds so I
mean even better if we can show lower
bounds for these strong systems
um and yeah okay I mentioned already
that we collapse this propositional
hardness because we can now arbitrate a
positional derivations you just do it in
one step
and it was also similar to what's
happening and solving in some settings
because they are also you use sub calls
a lot
okay so as mentioned these systems
eliminate propositional hardness and now
the question is what will we have in
these systems that's what we want to
understand
and the answer is exactly circuit
complexity hardness and so what remains
hard for these systems once you filter
away the propositional hardness is
exactly sorted lower bounds
okay and here um
you've got a result that makes this more
precise
and this is a precise characterization
so we have we now want to to know
whether there are hard formulas in q
freger
and we can say that this such formulas
exists we have super polynomial lower
bounds for Q flag if and only if they
exists either lower bounds or
propositional Trigger or their axis
lower bounds for non-uniform nc1 because
these are the lines the trigger works
with and more precisely the condition is
that P space shouldn't be contained in
non-uniform nc1
and this is a this is a this is an if
and only if yeah
so I mean this is the central problem
improve complexity this is one of the
central problems in circuit complexity
and to all of these two is exactly the
question whether we have lower bounds
for Q3 in the Quantified setting
and if you use these NP older Goods that
I defined on the last slide you can
formulate this alternatively for this
system Q frame with an MP Oracle and
then of course you lose the first case
so the first case disappears because
that can't happen anymore so then you
get in a precise equivalence you have
super polynomial lower bounds for this
system if and only if P space is not an
NC one
and I mean this just doesn't work for
free but it works for all the fragrance
systems that that I defined before so
you can use also extended trigger then
this is equivalent to
lower bonds for people and it works for
all the usual trigger systems that I
mentioned previously
um
okay so maybe just just a word on how
how this actually works so what what
happens
um the heart of this is by is this
Paradigm of strategy extraction which is
really unique for qbf and you don't have
a propositional analog of this so what
is strategy extraction that corresponds
to this two player game I defined before
whenever you have a false formula
there must be a winning strategy from
the for the universal player
now what we can do for these systems is
we can actually form a proof extract the
winning strategy for the universal
player so we start with a proof and from
the proof we extract the winning
strategy
in fact this is also used in solving to
certify answers so similar to what Jakob
talked about in the in the morning
um and it turns out that the model in
which you can do this strategy
extraction is a simple computational
model called decision lists
and I Define c decision lists yes what
is this
decision lists are a bunch of if then
statements you have a condition that you
evaluate and in this case the condition
is a circuit invaluables X1 to xn
and socket in the class C and if this
evaluates to one then you set a variable
U to a value B1 where B1 is either 0 or
1. and if this condition didn't hold
then you go to the next line and so on
and otherwise you have a case where you
set u to ca plus one so it's a very
simple computational model which
actually originates from machine
learning in the in the 80s
and what we can show is that
our Las Vegas systems have strategy
extraction and precisely this model in C
decision lists and this means that from
a refutation pi
of a formula so let's say x are the
existential variables of the formula U
are the universal variables you can
extract the polynomial time a collection
of C decision lists Computing a winning
strategy on the universal variables so
for each Universal variable you get a
decision list that computes exactly the
value of the counter strategy depending
on the inputs X which the existential
player sets
okay and then it's not I mean once you
have such a decision list it's not
actually hard to turn this into a
circuit so the yearly conditions where
circuits but you can turn this into one
single circuit
um which better depths increases by two
yeah so
and what this means is that if you look
at that Steve frag for instance you have
strategy extraction with circuits of
steps D plus two
but if you have ac0 then this class 2
doesn't matter and you get strategy
extraction ac0 likewise for ac0 mode p
and the other classes
yeah so we have a strategy extraction
more or less exactly in the
computational Paradigm on which the
lines live
okay and uh
now we can immediately exploit this for
lower bounds
and for this we just need to quote some
functions into qbfs and we can do this
very simply and say so let F be any
Boolean function total Boolean function
on the variables X
I Define a qbf we call it qf which is
saying there is an input X such that for
all that that is different from f
in other words this just means that
there is an input such that FX is
undefined
I mean this is this is clearly a
contradiction if this was a total
function
yeah and you can express this I mean you
can and you have the circuit uh if you
have a circuit that computes F same P
poly then you can simply use auxiliary
variables to describe the computation
and write down this into a CNF formula
so it's a sigma C formula
um
but the crucial thing is that the only
winning strategy for the universal
player is to place that equal f of x you
know the only way he can win on this
formula is by playing Z equal f of x
there's only one universal variable and
that's the only thing he can do to win
so strategy construction has to compute
F that's the crucial observation here
and now you can put this into a lower
bounds immediately so let's say you
start with I mean just for the simplest
case you have a function for hard for
depth 3 of which we have many this will
be hard for Pure resolution right you
start with a refutation of qf and Q res
by strategy extraction we know we can
get a decision list we know that this
decision list
is can be translated into depth C
uh F was hard for depth C hence time
must have been long
yeah so this is very simple
and exactly the same strategy you can
use now for all the other examples and
you see that we I mean buy this recipe
we get really strong lower bounds in the
setting for instance we can we can take
the the circuit lower Bound for parity
that's known for ac0 mod P
and as a coordinary we immediately get
the socket The Fragile lower bounds for
qbf for ac0 mod P figure yeah
which we don't have in the in the
propositional setting
or we could use the hardness of the mod
formula molecule formulas for ac0 remote
P circuits where p and Q are different
times
and then if we represent this correctly
then we can show this is actually that
that ac0 mod P and ac0 mod uh Q frag are
incomparable for different P's and
queues yeah because they will be hard
for ac0 mod P but will be easy for ac0
mod Q
uh and particular this means that ac01.p
will be exponentially weaker than tc03
which again we don't have in the
propositional domain
or you can use separations between the
different depths so for instance we know
that these sipsa functions they separate
depth D minus one from depth C circuits
you can plug this in again but here you
get this I mean this addition of plus
two when we did this translation of
decision lists into circuit so the so
the gap
bidens a bit and you Gap it you get a
gap of three
so these Q sips are functions will be
hard for depth D minus three
but easy for depth Steve
and what's nice here is that this is
actually a quantity provide C and F so
the separation doesn't depend on the
depth of the formula again this is
something we don't have in the
propositional word
okay so um
what this picture shows is
propositionally we don't know how to
exploit lower bounds for ac0 mod P but
in qbf we can match exactly any kind of
progress that we have in in the circuit
World by the strategy extraction
mechanism yeah
okay so maybe in the last five minutes
or so uh let me say what happens for
this solution because that that case is
somehow a bit different
question is can we characterize qbf
resolution also by Circuit complexity
and this is particularly interesting
because the solution corresponds quite a
bit to solving uh Benjamin will actually
talk about this in the afternoon
and the answer is yes we can do this
it's again a decision list model but we
need to adapt it slightly
and this actually has nice consequence
because as a sort of byproduct you get a
size width result I mean uh similar to
the size of its result that you know for
positional resolution but the different
formula actually you get this as a
quality to this characterization
okay so what's the circuit model here
again it's a generalization of this
decision list model which is which I
mentioned goes back to the 80s
uh but now we have to generalize it to
multi-output decision lists before with
all this Computing just one variable now
we have to compute it have compute
multiple outputs I mean but it's really
straightforward yeah so we have input
variables X1 to X N these are the
existential variables and we have output
variables U1 to u m these other
universes
otherwise my list looks exactly as
before yeah I have here terms on the X
variables and the B's are total
assignments to the U variables and we
call this a unified decision list
because in a sense this unifies all
these single output decision lists that
we had before
okay and what turns out is that this
precisely again characterizes Q
resolution
in the following sense that if you have
a false qbf uh of we need bounded
quantifier complexity that's uh that's a
restriction
um then the size of the smallest QRS
refutation in an NP or again is
polynomial related to the size of the
smallest Julia
so up to a polynomial Factor udl size
which you can understand as a circuit
measure will be equivalent to the
solution size
for bounded depth formulas
and you can I mean if you don't like
this NP article you can again formulate
it differently and say if you have a
form a sequence Phi of bounded
clarification this is hard for Qs if and
only if this requires large udls or
there is some propositional resolution
hardness inside which in fact you can
precisely pinpoint yeah
okay so just to compare to the previous
results where we had this
characterization for frieger and the
hardness was exactly the the circuit
classes were exactly the lines that the
system operates with yeah
uh working with lines from C was
characterized exactly by hardness for
sea circuits this is now a bit different
because
in resolution we obviously developed
with C and F so you can think of tabs
two circuits perhaps
and the complexity and truly the
complexity of decision lists
and hence also our udl model is known to
be strictly intermediate within depth 2
and depth 3 circuits that's a
result-back houses so it's so somehow
there isn't this type correspondence
anymore between what the line or the
complexity of the lines is and what the
complexity of the circuit model is yeah
if you translate these udls into
all the depth circuits you strictly
arbitrary in depth 2 and depth three
yeah so that means the characterization
so the circuit model is slightly
stronger than what the proof system uses
okay so I have uh well just just a bit
on the proof One Direction is again
strategy extraction that I explained
before for here you go from post to
circuits
uh you have to combine these strategies
into one udl and this is where you get a
blow up this is what depends on the
quantifier complexity
and for the other direction
you basically intuitively you prove that
the strategy extraction is correct so
you so you're in your proof you somehow
show that the strategy you extracted
plus the algorithm is sound
now at least you can prove another
solution
and it's also what you do on the state
assistance
all right so let me just uh conclude
what I try to show today is that this
puzzle between how circuit complexity
corresponds to proof complexity really
has a very neat and tight answer in the
Quantified setting
it works for these Vegas systems it
works for qbf the solution uh and I mean
I didn't really demonstrate this but
this really allows to very nicely and
very simply prove many lower bounds yeah
also for the solution
it would be nice to I mean get the full
characterization for a solution where
you don't necessarily work with
unbounded qbfs but the udls we've got at
the moment they are probably too weak so
they don't they're not the right model
would be also very nice to do a similar
characterization for hoof systems that
actually correspond to actual uh solving
so the so the methods that are used in
2bf solving
and yeah also other theoretical systems
like cutting planes polynomial calculus
it's not completely clear how what this
characterization would look like
[Applause]
questions
what would you have to change if you
wanted to capture some fixed alignment
of the polynomial Iraq the universal
production Loop that answer to
specialize
no you can simply I mean you you were to
restrict your formulas to be of bounded
of
other complexity and all the formulas
you would work with would also be of the
permanent complexity so if you want to
have the case level then you would just
let the sigma case formula so it's
perfectly fine you can you you can do
that yeah and that would work SPS before
and the essential list that's the length
of the display are all in that case
[Music]
when we start from the proof and expect
the winning strategy which we compute in
this udls then what we technically do is
we first construct the single output
decision list that's easy we get I mean
these are linear in the size of the of
the proof but when we want to combine
them into one udl into one combined list
which we need to do because otherwise
this model is not the right one
uh then we get an explosion and that
depends on the quantifier complexity so
if you have qualifier alternations de
quantify alternations then we get uh do
the L of size n to the T thank you
the last regarding the last slide you
said that there are like a system
corresponding to qvf solver we mean that
like well can you make it a quick
example of what is a something that
solver do that it's not like this uh for
Universal reduction
right so in fact I mean I mean we talk
more about this in the afternoon but uh
but qcdc ads are having for instance so
that's the lifting of cdca to the 45
Paradigm so what they use you you again
can extract uh proofs from qcdcl in some
qbf resolution system but it's a more
powerful system than the qbf the
solution system that I showed you so it
uses some additional I mean in this qbf
system I was somewhat mysteriously
saying
um
that uh
you have this condition that uh whatever
you realize a resolution must not be a
tautology
yeah I mean if it was an existential
tautology would be completely fine but
if you realize Universal apology and
then couple of this Universal reduction
that might lead to problems but
sometimes you want to do this in solving
so you have a system which is more
powerful actually actually exponentially
more powerful which is called long
distance resolution and for long
distance resolution for instance we
don't have such a nice characterization
so that would be really nice because
then we would kind of characterize by a
circuit model what's going on a qcdc ad
solving for example
any more questions
okay
foreign